all right ma we'll go ahead and get
started here we'll open up for questions
let's start with uh dave mcminiman with
espn dave go ahead
jamal congrats on the win um when you
look back at this series
months from now maybe even years from
now what do you think is going to stick
out in your memory
[Laughter]
no it was it was a good it was a good
series
um definitely the most fun series i've
played in
um respects to utah jazz respects
donovan
uh it's a great battle um
i don't know what's the same speechless
he played so good you know every game
putting pressure on us
mix it up he played without fighting
play with the heart
we got the best of him today
all right next we'll go to mark kizla
mark go ahead
hey jamal so many great moments tough
moments uh competitive moments
i want you in this series i want you to
talk about that moment right at the end
of the game where you went over to
donovan and picked them up there um
why'd you do that why
yeah why just tell me about
what was going on there i i know why i
want you to tell me why
it was an amazing duel i mean
you just build this team every game win
or lose and he had that fight
um and you gotta show respect but we you
know we talk off the court too
and you know just we're both adidas guys
we see each other often so uh
i'll pay respects to him it was a great
battle and and it's not going to be the
only one either
and we expect to see each other a lot
down the future and um you know he
raises about play the game upgrades his
and we go at it it's a whole lot of fun
you know we bring the best out of each
other so
um it was like i said it was just a
really good series a lot of fun to play
all right next we'll go to tj mcbride tj
go ahead
hey jamal come on
what can you say about gary harris's
ability to come in and make this kind of
a defensive
impact after not playing for so long
going all the way back to march
i think it was like march 11th uh what
is his first game
um this is only the second game in six
months it was crazy
maybe that's too much on offense you
know still trying to get his uh
his flow back but you know defense
to not play for six months come back and
make that kind of impact you know in two
games
that's for his team right there and uh
he's the best defender i know
uh when he guides me in practice um
there's no way in the nba that grabs you
better than gary
um and you can see when he's out in the
car he's just
he's like a football player the way he
moves his feet and shuffles and slides
and
his anticipation he's got quick hands
he's got the whole package on defense so
uh you know he's he was a game changer
for us
all right next we'll go to joe vardon
who's there right now joe go ahead
in almost any other series ever this
would be ridiculous
even asking this but michael was talking
after the game
that because of everything that's going
on in the bubble and how hard it is
like a question comes up like do we even
want to prolong it
and you guys ended up fighting through
and winning all three games but was it
was there any point where you guys had
to talk about that about
do we want to fight to win these games
and continue to live like the tough life
that you have to live
we just decided we're going to be here
we're going to be here simple as that
we're going to go home
and then we're all going to go home and
everybody's going to go separate i'm
going to go back to canada joker's going
back to serbia like
you know we're not going to accomplished
so as an nba as as
as the players we came together and said
no if we can get more done by being here
um you know it's not ideal but um this
is an idea for anybody you know so
we made a decision as a team as an nba
to you know stay here
and if we're going to be here as a team
we're going to be here so we had that
belief from beginning
down 3-1 um there's no panic and we just
you know we kept our poison
um close to the series so all right
we did a good job of staying focused and
staying on track
all right next we'll go to mike singer
mike go ahead
hey jamal two-part question first of all
how much did that uh
ingles knee to your thigh affect you
throughout the game
a and b what were the conversations like
in the fourth quarter everything sort of
bogged down
that you know i think you guys ended up
scoring 15 points you had a six minute
drought
what were the conversations like trying
to just grind out
points in that fourth quarter my thigh
is good it was just it was just stiff a
little coming out of half
um other than that it was fine i'll be
good um and
it was a defensive game you know both
teams missed a lot of good looks like
shots that we've made in all series um i
only had 17 and don only had 22.
like we've been it's kind of weird now
uh
joker joker you know put us on our back
and he was big on the stretch tori was
amazing
the area like i said um we knew it was
missed or made we had to put defense we
had to get rebounds and run and
uh you know focus on that by the end so
78 to 80 is a
pretty real grimy game seven score
next we'll go to jeff zilgit with usa
today jeff go ahead
jamal down 3-1 what was more taxing
the mental aspect of it or the physical
aspect to get back and win this series
and why
both
mentally having a day off and having a
big game
it's a lot to you know keeps a lot to
sustain um
that mental focus um especially when
teams are
you know especially when they're trying
to do everything they can to disrupt
your offense and
and make you think a little bit and
switching everything up you know a day
in between is
is real tough um i wish i had a couple
more days before the clippers but
uh you know like i said as we got it's
gonna be toughest championship to win
because we all will be mentally tough to
stay here and
and uh they'll get through that you know
so we've been here for like
56 days i think seven days um
and we don't plan on leaving so we gotta
switch our focus to thursday no enjoy
this midnight and just
get back get some rest and prepare for
clippers
all right we have time for one more here
and we'll end with uh om yung maisuk
with espn home go ahead
jamal congratulations uh nicolas said in
his post-game interview that he couldn't
leave you hanging after how well you
played this entire series
he had 30 and 14 he's had 20 and 10 in
all the game sevens he's played
only duncan lebron and dirk have done
that in game
in that many game sevens i was wondering
what did you think of him tonight
he does everything you know posts up and
shoots it he passes he pushes the pace
he's smart
and you know like i said we need him
today we definitely need him today and
he made clutch baskets and just kept us
poised i even went out and have it going
or i miss some bunnies or
you know we messed up on defense and
they made their push especially in the
third quarter and beginning the fourth
you know he just well he was our leader
for you know for that second half and
now he did it all so you know he's gonna
be all in favor one day
all right jamal we appreciate it man
thank you congrats on the win man